when it comes to drinking everyone has
their own particular method but the
really heavy drinkers are the creatures
that feed on nectar when you get almost
all your energy from sugar water you
need to drink a lot
hummingbirds for instance flick their
tongues in and out of a flower 15 to 20
times a second and scientists have only
recently discovered exactly how their
specialized tongues work but nectar
drinking bats have proved more of a
problem
some of them lap up nectar with a hairy
tongue dipping rapidly in and out of
this fake flower pretty simple but
videos of orange nectar baths revealed
but when they drink their tongues are
hardly moving scientists think that they
may be using some combination of
capillary action and tiny muscular pumps
drawing nectar up the long grooves on
either side of the tongue however it
works it's not like any other tongue we
know of but we do know it has to be
efficient because that's like these
consume 150 percent of their body weight
in nectar each night now those guys can
really drink meanwhile the rest of us
will just have to manage as best we can